قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان اتفاق
السلام مع الامارات جاء من منطلق القوه
وانه ليس مشروطا بالتفاوض مع الفلسطينيين
مشيرا الى ان الجانب الاقتصادي من الاتفاق
سيعود بمنافع كبيره على اسرائيل وقال ان
دولا اسلاميه وعربيه تطلب التقرب من
اسرائيل بسبب
قوتها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما الرسائل التي تحملها تصريحات
نتنياهو الى مواطنيه الاسرائيليين والى
الامارات والدول الاسلاميه والعربيه وما
تفسير استمرار التوسع الاستيطاني في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه بعد اعتبار تعليق خطه
الضم الاسرائيليه انجازا لاتفاق التطبيع
الرسمي بين الامارات
واسرائيل
[موسيقى]
اعتبر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو ان اتفاق السلام مع الامارات يعكس
تغييرا في مواقف كثير من الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه تجاه اسرائيل وفي كلمه امام
الكنيست خلال بحثه التصديق على الاتفاق
الاماراتي الاسرائيلي اوضح نتنياهو ان
دولا عربيه واسلاميه تسعى للتقارب مع
اسرائيل بسبب قوتها العسكريه والاستخبارات
والتكنولوجيه والاقتصاديه وقال ان التوصل
الى الاتفاق مع الامارات جاء من منطلق
القوه وقوه ردع على حد تعبيره ونفى وجود
اي ملاحق سريه او بنود غير معلنه في هذا
الاتفاق نتابع جاربا من
كلماته هكذا يبدو السلام الحقيقي سلام في
مقابل السلام سلام من منطق القوه وفضلا عن
حقيقه ان الاتفاق مع الامارات المتحده غير
مشروط بمفاوضات مع لينين هناك ثلاثه امور
تجعله متميزا اولا ليس فيه اي تنازل عن
اراض من وطننا التاريخي ثانيا هذا سلام
دافئ بين الشعوب ثالثا ينطوي هذا الاتفاق
على مركب اقتصادي عظيم ففيه قوه هائله
لاقامه علاقات تجاريه وعلميه واستثمار وفي
مجال الطيران والسياحه
والزراعه تصريحات المسؤولين الاماراتيين
التي فق الاعلان عن اتفاق تطبيع العلاقات
مع اسرائيل قالت انه يضع حدا لتقويض حل
الدولتين عبر تعليق خطه الضم الاسرائيليه
للاراضي الفلسطينيه غير ان مجلس التخطيط
والبناء في الاداره المدنيه التابعه
لسلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه بالضفه
الغربيه وافق على خطط لبناء
371 وحده استيطان جديده ويرتفع بهذا عدد
الوحدات الاستيطانيه التي تمت الموافقه
عليها خلال يومين الى نحو 5000 والى اكثر
من 12000 وحده استيطان خلال العام الحالي
وفق حركه السلام الان يذكر ان هذه هي
المره الاولى التي يجتمع فيها مجلس
التخطيط والبناء الاستيطاني بعد تطبيع
العلاقات مع الامارات والبحرين ونقلت
مصادر مقربه من رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو قوله انه بعد توقيع
اتفاقيتي التطبيع لم يعد هناك سبب لاعا
البناء الاستيطاني وانه اوعز الى مجلس
التخطيط والبناء باستئناف التصديق على
مشاريع استيطان
جديده لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القدس سامي ابو شحاده عضو الكنيست من
القائمه العربيه المشتركه من واشنطن توفيق
حميد الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وفي
الاستوديو حسن البراري استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه قطر اهلا بضيوف وابدا
بضيفي من القدس سامي اب بحده فيما يتعلق ب
ما اراد نتنياهو ايصاله اليوم من خلال
مقاله في الكنيست والحديث على انه سلام من
موقع القوه كما قال نتنياهو ماذا اراد ان
يقول نتنياهو للداخل الاسرائيلي
اولا نتنياهو اراد ان يقول ان الروايه
الصهيونيه وال يعني الشعور بالاستعلاء على
العالم العربي كان هو الخيار الصحيح من
ناحيه نتنياهو ومن ناحيه الحركه الصهيونيه
وهو يشعر الان بانتصار كبير على علينا نحن
كفلسطينيين وهو من خلال هذه الاتفاقيه
يريد ان يقول انه لا يوجد اي مشكله مع
العالم العربي من خلال عدم حل القضيه
الفلسطينيه وعدم التوصل الى حلول مع
القياده الفلسطينيه هو يستطيع ان يتجاوز
الفلسطينيين من خلال قيادات عربيه اخرى
وان يعمل كل ما يريده في العالم العربي
والاسلامي من دون ان يكون هناك اي حاجه
لارجاع الاراضي الفلسطينيه لاقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه لوجود حلول عادله للقضيه
الفلسطينيه هو يريد ان يكون على نظريته في
كل ما يتعلق في العلاقه مع العالم العربي
والاسلامي كانت هي الصحيحه ا ابقى معك
السيد سامي ابو شحاده مساله تقنيه فيما
قدم عندما قدم هذا النص اليوم في الكنيست
لاعضاء النواب او نواب في الكنيست
الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق بخطه السلام
الاسرائيليه العربيه الحديث عن ثلاث نسخ
بالعربيه والانجليزيه
والعبريه تم الحرص في النسخه العربيه
والانجليزيه على مصطلح التطبيع بينما تم
تجنبه في النسخه العربيه هل هذا
صحيح اه طبعا عزيزي انا قرات الثلاث نسخ
في اللغه العربيه والعبريه والانجليزيه في
في العنوان في اللغه العبريه والانجليزيه
وخلال النص في عده اماكن يعني يرجعون على
كلمه التطبيع بشكل دائم وفي النص
العربي كان هناك عده خلافات اولا لم تكن
هناك مقدمه في النص العربي بما يختلف عن
النص العبري ولا يوجد اي حديث عن صراع في
النص العربي وكل التصريحات التي خرجت من
القيادات والدبلوماسيين في الامارات ليس
لها اي علاقه بالنص النص لا يتحدث لا عن
وقف الضم ولا عن القضيه الفلسطينيه ولا عن
المسجد الاقصى ولا عن الاحتلال ولا على اي
شيء النص يتحدث في اللغه العربيه فقط على
صفقه اقتصاديه ولديها ايضا بنود سريه لم
تكشف لدينا اليوم في الكنيست واسرائيل غير
معنيه بالكشف عنها انا كنت سعيد جدا حقيقه
عندما قرات النص العربي رغم نفي رئيس
الوزراء بوجود بنود سريه سيد
سامي لا الجميع يعرف ان هناك بنود وستعرض
على لجنه الخارجيه والامن في الاسبوع
القادم وهي لن ت لن يجي بها اصلا الى ال
ضيفي من واشنطن سيد توفيق ساعود لك سيد
حميد واعذرني على المقاطعه ساذهب الى ضيفي
في واشنطن سيد توفيق حميد اذا ما قاله
صائب عريقات قبل مده حين التوقيع على
توقيع السلام او تطبيع الاسرائيلي
الاماراتي البحريني قال بان ما يتم
التوقيع عليه هو انما التوقيع على صفقه
القرن الامريكيه وهذا ما تثبته ما جرى في
هذه الايام من هذه المخططات لوحدات سكنيه
بالالاف ومن خطواته ما ذكره ضيفي قبل قليل
من القدس وبالتالي ما الرساله التي اراد
نتنياهو ان يصلها للدول العربيه غير مساله
التطبيع والموافقه على صفقه
القرن انا اعتقد في رسالتين مهمين حب
يرسلهم نتنياهو هنا الرساله الاولى هي
الحقيقه ان ان رساله
للفلسطينيين ان هم اذا لم يلحقوا
بقطار السلام فهم هيخسروا اكثر ا اما
الرساله الثانيه فهي بيحاول يعرض اسرائيل
كدوله قويه ولكن لو تلاحظ حضرتك انه لم لم
يقل ان ان ان السلام من منطلق القوه جاء
من منطلق القوه الاسرائيليه وليس القوه
الاماراتيه بل قال من منطلق القوه فهو
سلام بين قوتين يريدون السلام يريدون سلام
دافئ يريدون تحسين علاقات
اقتصاديه كبدايه ومثل حي لنجاح السلام في
المنطقه قد يتبع خطوات حل لمشاكل اخرى
فالرجل لم يقل انه سلام من منطلق قوه
اسرائيليه اذهب للكلمه اللي حضرتك لسه
بتقال في البرنامج هتلاقيه بيقول من منطلق
قوه ولم يقل فقط اسرائيليه فهي قوه
اماراتيه ايضا فالامارات في وضع قوي من
عده جوانب ودوله متطوره في العديد من
الامور وسلام الاقوياء يكون لاما ثابتا
راسخا اعتقد هذا هو ما اراد يقولون
للمجتمع لم تجبني على
سؤالي
امم ما هي النقطه التي تريدها تماما
بالضبط سالتك اي نقطه سالتك تحديدا بما
قاله صاحب عقات بان التوقيع على اتفاق
التطبيع الاماراتي البحريني الاسرائيلي
انما هو توقيع على صفقه القرن وان ما يجري
في هذه الايام من اعتماد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على وحدات سكنيه جديده وايضا
النص الذي كتب به ما قدم لاعضاء الكنيست
انما هو تكريس لهذا المبدا اوم هذا السقف
الامريكي فيما يتعلق بالسلام العربي
الاسرائيلي الذي يتم الدعوه
له نعم
هو يعني ما قلت حضرتك ان ان الامر هو
تطبيق عملي لصفقه القرن الامريكيه نعم
صفقه القرن الامريكيه كان مضمونها ان
الامور الاقتصاديه و ممكن هي لا تحرك
السلام بدلا فقط من امر الارض مقابل
السلام ن ل دعنا نتجه لشيء اخر فهو ده كان
تفكير الامريكان ان يفكر خالج الصندوق
بحلول اخرى بان يعطي مثلا رائعا الاقتصاد
ينمو بين دولتين وتزدهر المنطقه بسببه فهو
نعم اوافقك انه هو تطبيق عملي للفكره
الامريكيه واما بالنسبه للامر الفلسطيني
انا ذكرته ان هو رساله واضحه لهم انهم اذا
لم يلحقوا بقطار السلام فهم بيخسروا ارض
يعني كلما تاخروا في الجلوس في المفاوضات
ومحاوله الحصول على اتفاق لهم يفيدهم كلما
خسروا اكثر فاكثر اعتقد هذه الرساله واضحه
لهم استاذ حسن براري فيما يتعلق بما اراد
نتنياهو ان يقوله في كلمته امام الكنيست
قيل الكثير عن هذا التطبيع قال
بانه مجامله هديه لترامب في حملته
الانتخابيه قيل على ان الاداره الامريكيه
ايضا وضعت سقف فيما يتعلق بصفقه القرن واي
دوله ستلتحق دوله عربيه او اسلاميه فهذا
هو السقف ما الذي اراد نتنياهو ان يوصله
من خلال مقاله اليوم في ظل هذه السقوف او
هذه المقاربات نتنياهو يؤكد على امرين هما
يشكلان العنوان الابرز لكل الحركه التنقيح
هي الصهيونيه من جابوتنسكي الىى هذا اليوم
اولا ان السلام لا ياتي الى نتيجه القوه
والقوه الاسرائيليه وهنا انا اختلف مع
الاستاذ حميد من واشنطن هو تحدث عن قوه
اسرائيليه بشكل واضح بمعنى ان ان الجدار
الحديدي اصطدمت في كل المقاومه العربيه
امام هذه الصخره الاسرائيليه وبالتالي
استسلموا لواقع ان اسرائيل هي اقوى منهم
عسكريا وس الامارات قوه ايضا لا لا لا
الامارات ليست قوه ولي لا يمكن مقارنه
القوه الاماراتيه بالجبروت الاسرائيلي
وتحالفاته وقوته الممتده الامارات دخلت
لحسابات اخرى ليس لانها دوله قويه ولكنها
لانها دوله تحاول ان تستعين باسرائيل من
اجل تحقيق مشاريع على المستوى الاقليمي
بشكل بشكل واحد وبالتالي يعني علينا ناخذ
بهذا الا الامر ان نتنياهو يريد ان يقول
بانه ان المقوله اليمينيه التقليديه
الكلاسيكيه بان العرب لا يفهموا الا لغه
القوه وان اسرائيل انتصرت في معاركها وان
العرب من يعني منقسمون بهذا بهذا المعنى
فبالتالي هناك فرصه ذهبيه لاسرائيل لتستغل
حاله التردي العربي الانكشاف الاستراتيجي
العربي تغير قاعده الصداقه والعداء في
المنطقه العربيه سيوله التحالفات التغير
ايضا في الموقف الامريكي هو يوظف ذلك من
اجل ان يحقق مكسبا لليمين الاسرائيلي
للمقولة الان فقط يعني يساوم او يفاوض على
السعر ومن ثم يتم حشر الفلسطينيين و كانهم
سندويشه فبالتالي يخضع الفلسطيني لمنطق
حقيقه انه انكشف استراتيجيا وانه لا يملك
خيارات في تحالفاته الاقليميه ولا الدوليه
فبالتالي هو يمتثل للمنطق اليمين
الاسرائيلي القائم على الضم قضم الاراضي
وايضا كما قال هي ارض اسرائيل بين
والزوجين الكبرى يعني هذا الحلم
الاسرائيلي وهو يتحدث عن دوله يهوديه وهذا
تابوت ثقافي موجود في الثقافه السياسيه
لاسرا يه والاستاذ اسامه يمكن ان يتحدث
افضل منا حتى العرب حتى العرب
الاسرائيليين حتى العرب الاسرائيليين بني
جانز فضل ان يذهب ليكون في تحالف صغير مع
نتنياهو على ان يشكل حكومه بتحالف مع
العرب على اعتبار ان العرب لا صوت لهم
فيما يتعلق بالقضايا المصيريه لما لمساله
الهويه اليهوديه ط في ظل ما ذكره ضيوفي
حتى الان في هذه الحلقه القرارات
الاسرائيليه ببناء الاف الوحدات
الاستيطانيه قبلت بادانه من السلطه
الفلسطينيه وكذلك الاردن واعتبرتها حركه
السلامه الان الاسرائيليه مؤشرا على رفض
اسرائيل اقامه دوله فلسطينيه وقالت انها
توجه ضربه لامال تحقيق سلام اسرائيلي عربي
اوسع في ضوء هذا نسال عن تفسير ومغزى
استمرار التوسع الاستيطاني الاسرائيلي بعد
اقل من شهر من توقيع اتفاقيتي التطبيع بين
اسرائيل والامارات والبحر وهنا اسال ضيفي
من القدس السيد سامي ابو شحاده قبل قليل
ذكر ضيفي من واشنطن بان على الفلسطينيين
ان يلتحقوا الان هناك واقع هناك احلام
براقه في البعد الاقتصادي هذا التطبيع
الاسرائيلي الاماراتي بالدرجه ال الاولى
هل فعلا الان هي مسؤوليه الفلسطيني ان
يلتحق والا سيجد نفسه في معزل او سندويشه
كما قال ضيفي استاذ حسن قبل
قليل لا اعذرني انا بدي اختلف مع ضيفك
الامريكي اخي عبد القادر لانه اولا فلسطين
من ناحيتنا نحن كفلسطينيين لم تكن للبع في
اي لحظه يعني نحن لم نتعامل بلغه ترامب
وبلغه نتنياهو ولغه الامارات عن فلسطين
كصف ولو كنا نريد ان نبيع كان من زمان
انتهت القضيه الفلسطينيه واذا الامريكان
والاسرائيليين ما زالوا في عقليه الصفقه
نحن نريد ان نشتري ولا نريد ان نبيع
فلسطين لم تكن للمساومه ولا للبيع من
ناحيتنا نحن كفلسطينيين انا باعتقادي كمان
نقطه مهمه جدا لم اذكرها هي ان قراءتنا
لهذه الصفقه انها ليس هذه ه ليست عمليه
سلام من يقرا ما بين السطور ومن يقرا ايضا
بشكل واضح النص الذي قدم لنا الحديث يتم
عن صفقه اسلحه كبيره جدا من يحتفل في دوله
اسرائيل في هذه الصفقه يعني يمكنك ان
تراجع كل الصحف الاسرائيليه من يحتفل في
هذا الاتفاق في دوله اسرائيل هي شركات
الاسلحه على كافه انواعها هناك من شركات
اسلحه وشركات السايبر والاخصائيين في
الامن وفي الض دمار طيب اذا كان هذا هو
السلام الاسرائيلي للعالم العربي اي
المزيد من الدمار والمزيد من الحروبات نحن
لا نريد هذا السلام نحن لا نريد مثل هذه
الصفقات العالم العربي شبع من الحروبات
وشبع من الدمار ولسنا بحاجه الى اخصائيين
اسرائيليين للاستمرار في دمار العالم
العربي الحديث هنا ليس عن صفقه سلام انما
عن صفقه بيع اسلحه للامارات مع اخصائيين
اسرائيليين ولكن حتى بهذه خطوه سيد اسامي
الم ينكشف ظهر الفلسطين كما قال ضيفي هنا
في الاستديو بهذه الهروله او التوجه
العربي للتطبيع مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي ايضا هناك امر واقع سوف يجد
الفلسطيني امامه او في مواجهته وبالتالي
نتكلم عن وضع اخر يختلف تماما حتى منذ
بدايه القضيه الى
الان ما في شك انه من ناحيه الفلسطينيين
هذهه خيانه من ناحيتنا نحن كفلسطينيين ما
ما قامت به الامارات عندما يستعين القائد
الصهيوني بنيمين من نتنياهو علينا نحن
الفلسطينيين باخوته الاماراتيين هذه من
ناحيتنا خيانه ولكن مهم جدا ايضا ان يعرف
الجمهور وان يعرف كل العالم ان مع المشروع
الاستيطاني الاستعماري في فلسطين مع
المشروع الصهيوني لا يمكن الوصول الى
تسويه معقوله مقبوله على اي شعب لديه
كرامه يعني هذا الازدهار الذي يتحدثون عنه
الى الامارات لو اسرائيل كانت بدها
الازدهار للعرب كان شفنا هذا الازدهار
لدينا نحن كمواطنين 20% من السكان في دوله
اسرائيل انا اليوم قلت في خطابي على هذا
الموضوع قلت لهم مثل ما يعني مثل اي حاله
تريدين ان تعملوا ابو ظبي ودبي يعني ما هي
المدينه العربيه العظيمه التي قامت
بانشائها اسرائيل من اجل ان تقلدها
الامارات اسرائيل دمرت كل المدن العربيه
الفلسطينيه التاريخيه والحديثه اسرائيل
كامت بتدمير كل القرى هناك داخل دوله
اسرائيل المواطنين العرب تقريبا 100000
منهم يعيشون فيما يسمى كره غير معترف فيها
في القرن ال 21 عننا 100000 مواطن من غير
كهرباء وماء اذا كان هذا التطوير
الاسرائيلي انا باعتقادي لا الامارات بدها
اياه ولا اهلنا في البحرين بدهم اياه ولا
اي انسان عنده كرامه باشارات كلمه قلت بان
اهلنا في الامارات وكذلك البحير اسال ضيفي
من واشنطن السيد توفيق حميد وكان هناك
مجموعه من الاقنعه تتساقط كما يقول البعض
الامارات عندما طبعت مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
قالت باننا سعينا الى ايقاف عمليات ال
الضم لا شيء يدل على ذلك والدليل هذه
المستوطنات التي تبنى من جديد التطبيع
هديه للاداره الامريكيه ولا ندري كيف تخدم
الشعب الاماراتي الان ضيفي من القدس يتكلم
عن شركات الاسلحه وكذلك الشركات البرانيه
وغيرها المستفيده من هذه الصفقه وبدرجه
الاولى ايضا انقاذ نتنياهو من متابعاته في
الداخل الاسرائيلي وبالتالي عن اي احلام
ورديه وصفقات سوف تعود بالازدهار
الاقتصادي للمنطقه غير مصالح ضيقه ضحيتها
الاولى هو الشعب
الفلسطيني شكرا اخي الكريم على سؤالك
الحقيقه في عده نقاط هنا مش نقطه واحده
اولها ان الجانب الفائده ل الامارات حينما
تكلم عن انها تشتري معدات واسلحه تكنولوجي
من اسرائيل فاي قائد مخلص لشعبه لازم يجيب
لدولته افضل
معدات احنا نعلم العدو الايراني موجود
وانه يهدد ابن الامارات والسعوديه
والمنطقه من عده نواحي فلا لا اتعجب ان
انا كدوله او كقائد دوله ان يحاول ان يحصل
على احدث ما يمكن وافضل ما يمكن لمواجهه
هذا العدو الواضح امامنا الان بالنسبه لنا
على الاقل ا
النقطه الايراني العدو الايراني الذي
يحاول السيطره على لبنان ويحاول السيطره
على اليمن ويحاول ايقاع البحرين ويحاول
التسلح نوويا حتى يرهب المنطقه و و و يعني
احنا نتكلم هنا عن عدو واضح المقاطعه
س على المقاطعه فقط لاعطي اشاره لما ذكرته
الان دول الخليج وعلى راسها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من اكثر الدول في العالم
انفاقا على صفقات الاسلحه ومع ذلك في
تجارب يعني واقعيه الان ما يجري في اليمن
او استهداف منشات اقتصاديه هامه
واستراتيجيه بالنسبه للجانب السعودي لم
تنفع كل هذه الاسلحه وجر الاستنجاد
بالجانب الامريكي وعير ترامب السعوديه
ودول الخليج بانه لو يرفع يده عن هذه
الدول لمده ربع ساعه فالاي سوف يكون في
عواصم هذه الدول وبالتالي ما فائده كل هذه
الاسلحه انا اقول ل حضرتك لان اولا نوع
الاسلحه يختلف فقد يكون لدى اسرائيل اسلحه
متطوره في مواجهه الدرونز او الطائرات
الصغيره اللي اصابت ارامكو امريكا ممكن ما
تكونش عندها نفس درجه التطور في اللحظه دي
زي اسرائيل مع الدرونز دي نمره واحد نمره
اثنين ان الامر الايراني يمس اسرائيل
مباشره بنوع من الخطوره التي ممكن تنهيه
من الوجود اما بالنسبه للجانب الامريكي
فايران بعيده هي خطر ولكن ليس خطرا جاسما
على نفوسهم نفوسهم كما هو بالنسبه
لاسرائيل فاسرائيل الخطر الايراني بالنسبه
لهم هو عامل مشترك يجعل الكثير بالمنطق
يتعاونوا مع اسرائيل لدرء هذا الخطر الذي
ممكن يصيب ايه الطرفين لكن امريكا بعيده
عن هذا الامر لكن هناك نقطه اخرى احب
اضفها ان الامر ليس عسكريا فقط فالامارات
هناك مشروعات في التصور ان يتم عمليات نقل
ضاعه
بريا من خلال الاردن لاسرائيل ومنها الى
البحر الى اوروبا يعني هذه احد المشروعات
التي قد تدر مبالغ ضخمه على الامارات
وشعبها وقد تسمح لهم بوضع اقليمي قوي جدا
في حلقه التواصل في في نقل البضاعه في
الشعوب انا هقول لحضرتك بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين الامر هقول لحضرتك ان ان ضيفك
الفاضل
من اسرائيل بيتكلم عن اللي هو عضو الكنيست
بيتكلم عن ان ان الامر فيه من القدس
معذره بيتكلم ان الامر فيه خيانه
ا الخيانه لمن يعني لابد ان يراجع نفسه
الخيانه لمن يعني هل يعاتب على الامارات
انها مخلصه لشعبها وانها تريد ان تحصل له
على افضل صفقه تجاريه واقتصاديه و
مستقبليه يعني هل هو ينتظر من قاده
الامارات ان يخونوا شعوبهم لاجل
الفلسطينيين يعني انا لا ادري
هو يتكلم عنهم كانهم خونه خون سامي فقط 30
ثانيه ليرد على هذا السؤال الوجيه وساعود
لك استاذ حسن اعذرني
لا انا انا عزيزي عبد القادر تمام العكس
انا انا اقبل لو كان هناك مجال لو في هناك
نظام حكم ديمقراطي في الامارات وكان في
مجال لاجراء استطلاع راي مع نقاش ماذا
يريد الشعب الاماراتي ما يريد اهلنا في
الامارات انا متاكد ان الاغلبيه الساحقه
من اهلنا في الامارات كما راينا في المؤشر
العربي تاريخيا وانا على ثقه تامه انهم
سيكونوا مع القضيه الفلسطينيه ومع
الفلسطينيين الاماراتيين لا يتعاملون مع
فلسطين كصفه تجاريه بقي معي تقريبا دقيقه
ونصح لضيف استاذ حسن براري
اذا هل مازال هناك مجال لوضع ب بعض
المساحيق والحديث على ان خطه التطبيع او
السلام راعت مصلحه الفلسطينيين وقفت او
دعت الى وقف عمليات الضم اما ان الواقع قد
اسقط جميع الاقنعه وبالتالي نتكلم عن وضع
يختلف تماما عما كان انا بتقديري المساله
ليست مساله تطبيع يعني تجاوز الج الجانبان
هذه المساله مساله تحالف هم يتحدثون عن
تحالف في تبادل صفقات تسليح في هناك اراء
مشتركه فيما يتعلق بهويه العدو يعني
يقولوا ان ايران هي عدو للامارات وهي ايضا
عدو لاسرائيل الاسلام السياسي ممثلا
بالاخوان المسلمين هو عدو للطرفين تركيا
وسياسه تركيا في الاقليم ومجالها الحيوي
ايضا يشكل تهديدا للطرفين كما يقولوا
وبالتالي نجد الامارات مع اسرائيل دائما
في الخندق المضاده تركيا في شرق المتوسط
وفي ليبيا وفي كل هذه الم والفلسطيني س في
الحسابات الفلسطيني بالنسبه للامارات
القضيه الفلسطينيه لم تكن قضيه مركزيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه كانوا يعطوها يسمى
الليب سيرفس بمعنى يعني الاهتمام اللفظي
التضامن العاطفي اللفظي اللي مالهش ثمن
لكن في واقع الامر ان الامارات تقيم
علاقات سريه والتحالف مع اسرائيل عمره
عقدين من الزمان لانها تعتقد بان اسرائيل
مفيده لها في مشاريعها الاقليميه لا تحتاج
الامارات الى السلاح الاسرائيلي ذكر ضيفي
وجود ملاحق سريه فيما يتعلق بهذا الاتفاق
هذا فيما يتعلق بالطائرات الاف 35 يعني هل
نتنياهو وافق على بيع امريكا لطائرات اف
35 لقاء هذا التقديم خصومه وعلى راسهم مشي
علون في حزب تيلم يقول بان هناك ملحق سري
ويجب ان يناقش هو ينفي ذلك لانه يريد ان
يحافظ على التفوق النوعي الاسرائيلي
فبالتالي لا يمكن حتى ان امام الراي العام
الاسرائيلي ان يثق بالجانب الاماراتي
ويمنحه طائرات اف 35 لكنه يبدو يبدو انه
توصل الى اتفاق مع ترامب بانه لا ضير في
بيع هذه الطائرات لانه يريد هذا الاتفاق
من اجل اولا اعطاء هديه لترامب في
انتخابات ثم يريد ان يعني ينفذ بجلده من
محاكمه قادمه له في في قادم الايام هو
يريد ان يستخدم هذا الاتفاق في سياق
السياسه الداخليه وايضا خصومه الذين
يقولون بان هناك في ملاحق سيريا
يستخدمونها ايضا في سياق اشكر تقويض سلطته
داخل اسرائيل دكتور حسن البراري استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه قطر شكرا جزيلا
لك وكذلك ضيفي من واشنطن توفيق حميد
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وللضيف من القدس
سامي ابو شحاده عضو الكنيست من القائمه
العربيه
المشتركه ختام هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء
شك
[موسيقى]
ن